Marvel's phase four of the MCU was
revealed about a week ago and we now
know what to expect but do we actually
know Marvel's plan are they going to be
building up phase four or five and other
phases much like they did phase one two
and three how's it going everybody it's
Warren and these are questions that a
lot of people have right now but luckily
for us Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios himself has weighed in on
what we can expect from phase four and
five including introducing and building
up new teams the New Avengers and a
crossover event as well so I'll break it
all down in this video be sure to
subscribe to my channel for your chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 and more
giveaway details at the end of this
video so we know all of the movies in
Phase for now and most of the movies
that are coming to phase 5 but what is
Marvel Studios as planned we know that
there's not going to be an Avengers
movie in phase 4 so the question is how
are they going to build up these new
characters is there going to be a new
Avengers team and is there going to be
some big crossover event well luckily
for us Kevin Feige commented on this
directly after the Hall H panel at San
Diego Comicon in regards to his plan for
phase 4 phase 5 and putting a different
spin on the MCU he said there is always
a bigger version and it sort of only
comes into view for others as it
solidifies so ask me again at the end of
2021
but I will say post in-game we were
always about the new we were always
about doing what we always tried to do
in phase 1 2 and 3 which is do a film of
a character you already know like Black
Widow in a way that you don't expect we
wanted to do our big and samba like we
did in phase 2 with guardians and that's
what Eternals is we want to bring in new
characters like shang-chi who's awesome
new versions of Doctor Strange Thor
continuing to surprise and change and
evolve so the first thing that Kevin
Feige starts off by saying is that
there's always a bigger version of the
plan and ask him about the plan again in
2021
so 2021 is the end of phase 4 so
basically what he's saying here is that
by the end of phase 4 after we've seen
all of these movies we will know what
everything is building up for so like
you said they're going to introduce new
characters like shang-chi and the
Eternals which is going to be their big
ensemble movie like the guardians of the
galaxy and then do different takes on
characters like dr. strange and Thor but
while they're doing all of this they're
going to be building up the bigger plan
of the MCU this is just like how they
built up fan o's and all of the Infinity
stones they didn't introduce them all at
once they gradually introduced them as
the tesseract as the scepter as the
ether and Fanus was in the background
the whole entire time trying to collect
all of the stones even though we didn't
really see him
so what Kevin Feige is saying about the
bigger vision is that this is all going
to be happening during phase four and at
the end of phase four in 2021 we're
going to see what all of that is leading
up to and like he said it only really
comes into view for others as these
movies play out but what he's saying is
that they are doing the same thing that
they did in the previous phases
everything that is going to happen
within all of these movies in the MCU is
going to build up and eventually
everybody is going to come together to
deal with what is building up and he did
confirm that there is going to be a new
Avengers team and a crossover event in
the future in a separate interview with
MTV right after San Diego comic-con Hall
H he was asked if there is going to be a
New Avengers and if he knows what that
team looks like and he said yes and he
said it's going to be very different
than anything we've seen before and in
that same interview Kevin Feige was
asked if he's already begun to plant the
seeds for the next big crossover event
like Secret Wars and he replied with yes
they have phase 4 and 5 and the next
five years planned out the space for
start to plant the seeds for whatever
we're gonna see because we obviously saw
that us the whole infinity saga the
seeds were planted way early on yes we
debated what we should announce today
should we announce four and five we've
planned them out we've got five years
down the road so even though it kind of
feels like the MCU is starting over
after Avengers in game they are still
going to build up some grand a crossover
event he has confirmed that there is a
bigger plan building up over the phases
there is going to be a new Avengers team
and there is going to be some big
crossover event and of course with
Marvel now being able to use the
Fantastic Four and the x-men in the MCU
we can be sure that this big crossover
event is going to be phenomenal so there
you have it even though there is not
going to be a new Avengers film this
phase Marvel
still building up their faces just like
they did the first three there's a
bigger plan behind everything which
means there's most likely a huge villain
behind everything there's going to be a
New Avengers team and a big crossover
event so be sure to let me know what you
think about Marvel's plan down below and
let me know who you think should be the
next big bad villain and again if you
would like a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment down
below with your favorite superhero or
villain so you can enter my giveaway
I'll be picking one winner for the Xbox
one or ps4 as well as some other winners
for some Marvel Legends items the
winners will be chosen as soon as I hit
500,000 subscribers as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof